it's march first 2017 and for the very
first time in quite a while I am getting
my monthly update video done at the
beginning of the month before anything
has happened so very happy about that
I'm going to talk about what we've got
coming up in March and what went on
during februari quite a lot of stuff and
I always like to begin by talking about
three big things so the first of these
is actually two things two lectures that
I'm giving March is Women's History
Month so I will be giving lectures
towards the end of the month on Mary
Wollstonecraft and on Princess Elizabeth
of Bohemia to really important early
modern female philosophers the second
thing is also multiple and I'll talk a
lot more about this in the March section
but I just want to put it out there on
your radar we're going to have a free
webinar and follow that up with also a
online seminar on Aristotle and virtue
these are going to happen about the
middle of the month and the last big
thing that I want to talk about big
thing number three is that I'm hoping
well actually I'm planning to have the
Aristotle Nick and McCann ethics online
classes available in our teachable
academy sometime later on this month so
what went on during the month of sebra
wary a few events not as many as in
previous months but we're gearing up
towards some very busy months ahead so
the we started the month off with one of
the lectures in that philosophers in the
midst of history talk series and this
time I focused on Plato Athenian
democracy and the Greek enlightenment
you can see the video for that link to
below in the video description we also
continued on with the worlds of
speculative fiction and this time we
talked about Madeleine Wingels time
quintet you know it starts with a
wrinkle in time and ends with a suitable
time very interesting
discussions that we had going on there
and the last thing that we did was we
had our second meeting of the MKE stoic
fellowship for those who are out of town
MKE is of course the airport designation
for Milwaukee so it means the stoic
fellowship for everybody in the
Milwaukee area and that went quite well
you know we had about 12 people this
time and had some great discussion some
of the key ideas and epic fetuses
enchiridion chapters one through five
what else well I engaged in a bit of
blogging not as much as I had originally
intended to I got a bit less done on
that although I did get quite a bit of
academic writing taken care of and some
popular writing as well which I've been
trying to carve out the time for I did
have a piece in stoicism today which
I'll link to below about anger again and
what Epictetus and the other Stoics
would have to tell us about it I shot
quite a few videos as you know i did my
normal quota of six half hour Hagel
videos per month and and we're now at
the very end if you're a patriot
subscriber we're at the very end of the
second no third to last portion of the
reasons section if you're not a Patrian
subscriber then you're a little bit
behind I release those videos ahead of
time for those who are my patreon
supporters did some you know videos of
course the various talks and I also did
two or three other videos that you might
find quite interesting so people have
been asking for me to do those personal
development you know who are the people
that are really important for me
philosophically who do I like you know
did i go through phases and i did some
of those videos last month and release
those so you can check those that will
put links to those below as well but I
also responded to a viewers question
that was getting asked of me quite quite
frequently so I thought I'd probably
should make a video for this and I did
and the question was well they're
actually three questions rolled in there
but the main question was is it
good idea for me to major in philosophy
and my answer was yeah it's a good idea
it's not necessarily going to lead you
becoming a professor that's very tough
these days but if you're interested in
that you can you can watch that video
the other thing that I started doing
that I'm quite happy with are creating
some new core concept videos and these
are specifically focused on a text that
I'll be eventually developing a course
on aristotle's categories this is one of
those texts that students often get
assigned is like their first
introduction Aristotle and if you're
like me when you were a student you read
and you're like I have no idea what the
hell is not good right so I'm creating
some videos to help out students and
lifelong learners who run into this this
sort of stuff what else I did some some
collaborative work and some interviews I
got interviewed for a magazine called
Asia spa about stoicism i also got
interviewed for another website and
magazine called life after pain also
about stoicism that will be coming out
later this month of March I think and I
get you know I'm always involved in some
behind-the-scenes collaborations with
with some of the people that that I'm
involved with lot of these things takes
quite a bit of time to bring to fruition
what else I engaged in quite a bit of
philosophical counseling and coaching
and one hand and also quite a bit as
really interesting tutoring projects
mostly centering on stoic philosophy and
Aristotle a few things on some some
other issues as well so that was what
the month of febuary held let's talk now
about March so looking at the calendar
for March it's pretty packed I am
looking at all these dates and I'm going
to run through them fairly quickly some
of them i'll talk a little bit more
about after i get through the whole the
whole listing so
March eighth this would be a Wednesday
right March 8 5 p.m. central time we
start off the months activities with a
half-hour Hagel online Q&A session this
is open to anybody you can find a link
to it either you know on the Patrian
site or you can also find it like you
know my facebook i posted on Twitter and
those sorts of things so if you've got
any hagel related questions that is the
time and place to come remember central
time everything is central time don't
show up an hour late because you're
looking at eastern time march nine here
locally in the Milwaukee area 7 p.m. at
the brookfield Public Library will have
our third worlds of speculative fiction
talk of the year this is actually the
15th in the series and this one is on
Douglas Adams hitchhiker Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy series really
enjoyed rereading these I hadn't taken a
look at them for quite a while actually
since like College and going back quite
enjoyable so I'll be you know leading a
discussion about them talking about some
of the key philosophical themes if
you're in the area show up and was a
great conversation March 14th at 12 p.m.
central time we have an online event
it's a webinar which will be on
Aristotle and the virtues will be about
45 minutes long much of it will be
devoted to question and answer but I'll
talk more about that in a moment the
follow-up to that is going to be March
18th which is a saturday will have two
online seminars one at 10am and one at
4pm these are two hours long and each of
them will be on that same topic for the
month which is Aristotle and the virtues
but we'll be doing a much much deeper
dive and closer look in those seminars
March twenty first we have the first of
our Women's History Month talks this one
will be again at the brookfield
public library they want me to come in
and talk about somebody who I
particularly like at 7pm Mary
Wollstonecraft great 18th century she's
an 18 centric student live unfortunately
to the 19th century woman philosopher
you know writer of the vindication of
the rights of women but quite a few
other things that are what I'll be
talking about their march 23rd later on
that week 6 p.m. i will be giving
another talk in a new series women who
you should have read and we're
concentrating on philosophers primarily
modern philosophers although one from
the Middle Ages this year new series
that will be doing at the Shorewood
Public Library and this is on Princess
Elizabeth of Bohemia who is a really
interesting figure she had a
correspondence with Rene Descartes who
of course you know you've heard his name
he is a first-rank philosopher and she
sort of went toe-to-toe with him on some
of his key ideas so we'll talk about
that i'll also tell you a bit about her
biography and her involvement in the
ongoing protestant reformation that was
happening in Europe and all sorts of
other interesting bits of stuffing of
the you know QA afterwards and then
finally we wrap up the month on March
30th 6pm also at the hosted by the
Shorewood public library we have the MKE
stoic fellowship anybody who's
interested in stoicism you don't
actually have to be a stoic or know much
about stoicism you're welcome to come in
and we'll be talking about some key
ideas from Epictetus and karidian
chapters 6 through 15 but do you know a
lot of open conversation if it's as
collaborative sort of group a lot of fun
so that is all the stuff going on for
the month now I wanted to talk
specifically about the Aristotle stuff
coming up this month so before I talk
about the webinar or the seminars let me
tell you a little bit about the
course and why if you've been watching
my other previous videos you've been
saying well one is one of these course
is showing up I'm a bit of a
perfectionist and so I wanted to have
everything sort of just right before I
release them and I'm still in the
process of adding new content where I
think that things could be you know
improved you know whatever you're
developing online courses it's always a
you know ongoing process of maybe a
tweak here maybe a little bit more stuff
here so I am offering two courses one is
on nikka mccain ethics books 125 the
other nikka mccain ethics book six
through 10 they'll be bundled together
so if you're interested in taking them
together you can get a discount on them
but it's it's lots of you know great
material lecture videos lesson pages
tons of handouts worksheets you know
discussion questions with a discussion
forum for you to engage in quizzes you
know do all sorts of really cool stuff
so if you're interested in learning
about Aristotle this is a prime
opportunity I'll probably create a video
for each of those classes sort of little
teaser later on during this month so
that those are the classes now we've
decided that we're going to start doing
something that we dip their toe into the
water with a little bit last year with
an online seminar on Hagel's
master-slave dialectic last summer what
we're going to be doing is every month
going forward there is going to be a
free 45 minute webinar and then later on
that week the webinar will be on
Tuesdays later on that week there will
be a online seminar which it which is
not free but is going to be much more
intensive it's much more participatory
it's restricted to only 12 12 people
whereas the webinar Canadian optiv who
knows may hundreds right potentially but
this is this is for the people who
really want to
go into that material with me somebody
who's been studying it for you know
roughly 20 years so this first time
we're going to be concentrating on
Aristotle and the virtues so the webinar
I'll probably talk for about 15-20
minutes and then it's going to be Q&A so
any questions that people have about the
nick of mccain ethics virtues vices you
know what what temperance is really like
you know what is he talking about with
all this justice different kinds of
justice stuff that will be you know open
to anybody who wants to be in it for the
the online seminars that's something
where you're going to have to enroll and
we'll certainly have all sorts of links
and things for people to do that quite
easily if you enroll in the online
seminar you get a much more intensive
study of that and you know I'll be
providing some some new exclusive
handouts and a few other interesting
let's column you know incentives as well
so a lot of cool stuff coming up in
terms of Aristotle this month that leads
me into talking about the videos so I
will be continuing on with videos on
Aristotle's categories those core
concept videos really enjoying shooting
this new material I'm going to be doing
my you know usual six half hour Hagel
videos again if you're if you're a
patreon supporter then you're up to date
on those i stagger them a little bit so
people who are just in the general
public or seeing the released videos a
little bit later but you know we'll be
catching up as well with that I am going
to get that promise video on starts play
the flies or perhaps two videos done to
get that existentialism series back up
and running again something I've been
wanting to do for quite a while and you
know I'll probably do another current
event video
since there was quite a good you know
good reception to the last one on the
whole yeah some people didn't like the
hall but you can't please everyone and
I'm also going to be doing some more of
the personal videos some of those will
be about my philosophical development
and commitment but I'm also going to be
doing some videos that are more about me
as a person you know my life history
things I've struggled with you know
things that I particularly care about or
am involved with so i'll be doing some
of that i may in fact shoot a video like
that when i go up tomorrow to my alma
mater my undergraduate institution that
i haven't been to I've not been on that
campus since 1995 so it'll be
interesting to go up there i have a
meeting i'll talk about in just a few
minutes and it is yeah that's probably
enough said about that i mean you can
always watch the video when it comes out
so collaborations and interviews I've
got quite a few of that sort of stuff
coming up this month I'm doing some
interviews for a few sites I don't know
if they'll appear this month they're not
but I'm you know some of these are where
you they send you some stuff and you
right back and then there might be some
follow-up discussion so I'm doing that
for the daily stoic and for a site
called Phil skills which is about
philosophers who make a living outside
of the Academy but I'm also working with
a guy who's who's video work I
particularly like and who I enjoy
conversations with cliff sergeant he
does the better than food book reviews
so if some of you know him actually i'll
put a link to them so if you don't know
him you probably should go check him out
he does some really interesting work and
he and i are going to be doing a
conversation for what i think is
intended to be a podcast and it's about
books that changed a person's life so
i'm going to be talking in particular
about Plato's Republic Aristotle's Nick
and McCain
fixin Epictetus is discourses and so if
you want to know why I'm picking those
three you then you'll want to listen to
the interview when it comes out or
conversation maybe it's better I will
put it because we're both big talkers
and I think we'll probably have a lot of
back and forth what else so I mentioned
I'm going up to lakeland used to be
Lakeland College now it's Lakeland
University and I'm going up there
tomorrow to get the ball rolling on the
second stage of a very long process that
is intended eventually to lead to
something that is called a think house
presentation sort of like a TED talk
same kind of format it happens up in in
the area near lakeland hosted by the
Kohler art gallery and I'm sort of
workshopping something with them it's
really it's really cool process I'm kind
of happy to be involved with this and
I'm happy to do it you know with my you
know where I went to college it's kind
of cool to come back after 25 years
right so I'll be going up there and
doing that that's not going to happen
any time soon the actual talk that's
going to happen in the fall but but it's
a long process so I meet with the
committee tomorrow and they'll say well
how about some of this and some of that
or we don't like this can you can you
change this and we'll hash everything
out get some writing projects that I'm
working on still working on the stoic
dog Mata on anger book but that's
getting closer to fruition and also
working on the bigger stoic and Sohus
ism and anger thing and a lot of
curriculum development quite a bit of
other writing hopefully I'll get some
some stuff out in some of the other
blogs that I write for this month you
know as a guest poster like partially
examined life policy of truth and I
don't think I'll have anything in
stoicism today unless I unless I need to
bump up something that I've got written
for for them but I'll doing a lot of
editing work of course so that's all
all the writing stuff and the last thing
I'll say is any of you who are
interested in bringing the end to do a
talk or workshop we're still filling up
the calendar for quarters 2 through 4
for this year so if you're interested
just send me an email at Greg at reason
I oh also if you're interested in
philosophical counseling that's you know
using sort of techniques and ideas from
philosophy as resources for working
through various problems whether in
career or relationships or life same
thing email me at Greg at reason I out
if you're interested in doing tutorials
I offer those as well and guess how you
get in touch with me Greg at recently
huh so enough about all of that I hope
you have a great full month of March
ahead I hope to get a lot done myself
and I hope that it's a very prosperous
and productive for you